So here's how I started to think about it. So let's say how
can we represent the idea that we have an uncertain ending. We'll one way
would be if we had some kind
of generic probability distributions over the number
of rounds that the games going to be played. But this seems like an,
the simplest idea that I could think of. So here, here we have our,
two criminals, and what their going to do is their going to play a
round of prisoner's dilemma. But at the end of that round, they're going to
flip a coin. And with probability one minus gamma, that will be the last
round, it's all over. But with probability gamma,
they're actually going to play again. And, and they do
this after each round. And so each round
is, is basically statistically independent of the other rounds.
>> I see.
>> So the set up here is, with probability gamma,
the game continues. Now, notice that I chose gamma here.
This was a, it's representing a probability here, but in
the past, we've used this to represent a discount factor.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But that actually is the same thing, right?
In, in, in the normal discounting, we say that the
value that you get one step from now, is discounted
downward by gamma. And that's exactly what you'd take if
you worked out the expected value of a game where you
continued making steps with probability gamma. And with probability one
minus gamma, it ends if you get zero from then
until the rest of time. So every round here could
be your last, or not, right? It could be that you
actually get to continue playing. Does that make some sense?
>> That makes perfect sense.
>> Awesome. All right, so, so yeah, this is,
this is exactly that kind of situation where, well,
here, let me, let me ask you a question.
What's the expected number of rounds of this game?
>> Well, I'll bet it's finite if gamma's
less than one Yes, I even wrote that down.
>> Yeah, I'm smart. Or at least I can read.
>> Sure, but what's the, but, specifically we could actually write
it as a, as a, function of gamma.
>> Let's see. If gamma were something like, 99% then
I would expect it to be about a 100, right?
>> I think that's right.
>> Yeah.
>> So is that, is that your answer? [LAUGH] My function
of gamma is if gamma is .99 the answer is 100.
>> Yeah, something like that. It's not a total function but it's a function.
>> Well, it's a sample. I mean, you
do machine learning. Why don't you tell me what
the function would be given that sample.
>> Well, we can make it a quiz or I could just tell you.
>> Why don't you just tell me.
>> Alright. So one over one minus gamma
is the answer. It works for your example.
>> Um-hm.
>> 1 minus .99 is 100th and we're talking 1 over that so,
you get a 100. And, yea we could go through the argument as to
why that's that's what it is. But this one over one minus gamma
is what shows up all the time. If gamma is zero, then we're talking
about one over one. The game lasts one round. That's exactly what we'd expect.
>> Mm-hm As gamma gets closer and closer to one
this pro, this quantities getting closer and closer to infinity. So,
>> Right.
>> in fact if you know, it becomes unbounded as gamma hits one. So
yeah. So this is the expected of rounds, and so that means like yeah.
So as you said if gamma is 0.99, it's a 100 rounds. And we
already, reasoned that at a 100 rounds the whole thing falls apart. Right, huh,
and I noticed the one over one minus gamma, of course, is just like
the way we did discount factors, when we started doing MVP's in the first place.
>> Exactly, yeah, that, that kind of links them together.
>> Hm, that's actually kind of neat.